[Music]
in a world where every new release is
about small town kids on bikes having a
spooky Adventure in the 80s experience
the original film about small 10 kids
and bikes having a spooky Adventure in
the 80s that proves the actual decade
may not have been full of neon but it
was full of non-stop bullying do the
Truffle Shuffle come on do it
[Music]
those were the days epic voice guy the
best years of your life
and we all love the 80s right The
Goonies
experience a cult classic and that it
works best when you're young and
impressionable as you journey to
America's hairy armpit the Pacific
Northwest a location where you never
have to change the camera settings
because everything is always gray there
you'll watch five Future movie stars and
also these two pull off the most
realistic plan to stop gentrification
find some buried pirate treasure Meet
The Goonies a group of Misfit outcasts
who deal non-stop verbal abuse to each
other
you know I got some naked pictures of
your mom what you shut up about that
stuff shut up mouth you should have data
shut up shut up Mel shut up mouth shut
up yeah well at least I have a brain so
stupid now shut up maybe they're Misfit
outcasts because they're all little just
a thought Mikey is their leader and
Keeper of the goonie code
Never Say Die cooties always make
mistakes data does machines
[Music]
mouth is cool but rude
wait chunk can be a party dude Kenny
all right you know what that means hit
it does
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
ER and his Nebo baby want to repossess
their homes The Goonies will head off on
an adventure after these comedy bits
dozens of Comedy bits
and while they never say die they do say
Rich stuff a lot for some reason our
last chance to see if there really is
any Rich stuff
Rich stuff one-eyed Willy's Rich stuff
the last guy who went looking for the
woodstocks
come on Treasure kids it's treasure then
finally tag along as they explore the
hidden tunnels under their town and
discover the dark secret it hides below
shoddy Plumbing work
[Music]
thank you
it's like a magical Flint Michigan this
is supposed to be water
it's wet in it standing in their way are
the fratellis of Familia so Italian they
make a Roberto benini sounded like Chris
a pratt you sit too close to the
television so you're gonna screw up your
ammo they're criminals
Catholics and opera singers
so you might think of course they also
run an Italian restaurant
but that would just be perpetuating a
crude Italian stereotype
come on come on
Mamma Mia
so revisit the film everyone remembers
for its incredible pirate ship set
spielbergian mix of humor and horror and
one of Cyndi Lauper's greatest box
while overlooking how it takes forever
before anything fun happens there's
nothing exciting ever happens around
here anymore it's chock full of product
placement weekend
and relies on a cheap wing to the
director's other superhero films for the
big emotional payoff
but despite its flaws recapture that
magical feeling of what it's like to be
a little kid again still full of wonder
a sense of possibility and just really
loud and annoying
[Music]
[Applause]
shut up I'm old now
story
potatoes Pro country for young men the
Hollywood shuffler Stand By Me Oregon
Jones and the Temple of goon Don't Tell
Mom the babysitter almost died you have
to save Martha Wario and Waluigi Throw
Mama down the drain and me when I think
of a new Little Pond for the end of
these videos
[Music]
[Applause]
the goondock Saints
you're gonna live with me now dude he's
a person not a puppy he didn't just get
a new friend get your parents a full
grown ass man to feed
you know what I haven't had in a while
Big League cheese
imagine how long it takes a giraffe to
throw up Turd Ferguson that's a funny
name
I'll do you one better why is epic voice
over guy